[Music]
first of all congratulations your shows
a big hit you guys shoot it on this lot
and I wonder I I see some of the cast
around sometimes or people who work what
did we meet for both stirring our coffee
at Starbucks and you looked wonderful
that morning we were both talking about
how we needed our caffeine and we were
getting ready for the day okay well I'm
glad I wasn't too creepy or anything I
didn't do this I wouldn't retreat now
you've had obviously all this great
success but I mean it really just before
this show you were like a lot of actors
out here struggling you'd you'd worked
hard you did community theater done a
bunch of community theater I was a big
musical theater girl I did every musical
you can imagine I did am The Sound of
Music sound of music yes it's my
favorite movie and it's actually what
made me want to be an actress were you
the star with Maria I got my whole
entire extended family I'm including my
great aunt who was a nun who had been
you know helping me with the show and it
was opening night and the orchestra
started playing the opening song and I
was like so excited and I came out to do
the big like you know the best like the
big number and a set person had left a
piece of wood actually on the the hill
that I was just a walk down so I started
spinning and singing and ended up
tripping and rolling down the hill and
the orchestra stopped it's dead silent
in theater and my entire family in the
front row just burst out laughing like
wrapping up my great aunt who was a nine
is cracking up and then the orchestra
starts playing and I got up and I just
said with the sound of
yeah supportive family there now you're
a waitress on the TV show you waitress
in real life is that right I did at
Chili's shoes yes
good old Chili's yeah yeah I - wait
Chili's I don't know why we're doing
this I don't even know if they do they
run ads on herds they do boo competing
restaurants so I was a pretty bad with
your bad waiters
yeah I think I could ever do it again I
the first night by myself I had a whole
you know chili says the big beer glasses
the huge ones oh yeah and me being the
smart waitress that I was thought I got
this I can put them all on the tray and
carry it over and I'm strong and I did
Pilates fine whatever and then I ended
up dropping it all over my first table
it was a party of I think five or ten
people like all sitting at once and I
dropped it on them and your family had
flown in to see you humiliated and yeah
I mean we had weed a lot of crazy
customers at Chili's so I didn't feel so
bad - the next day when someone ordered
two Fujita's in case' Dilla I didn't
feel like that sounds really jerky
vagina vagina
vagina to go shows not going to air